I've got Hillary on the line Hillary how
are you I'm great
it's an honor to speak with you and I
gotta say I just started your book last
night oh well I see I like you I like
you a lot I appreciate you reading the
book so what what are you doing right
now what what are you attacking dead are
you building wealth yet
okay how much debt do you have we have
my husband and I have 51,000 total okay
would it break that four down for me
what's that fifty one thousand what's
that made up of about seven thousand is
a car loan and then the rest of it is my
student loans at forty three thousand
okay all right let's see I like Hillary
aid that you know your numbers all right
you know exactly what you owe on okay
this is fantastic so what's your
question for me yes we've been paying
you know over the minimum we've been
knocking this out you know I'm new I'm
new to the Dave Ramsey principles so I'm
just kind of starting to think more
intently about this my husband and I
actually have 90,000 in our personal
savings and checking right now it's just
sitting there now that includes
a thirty four thousand dollar bonus that
my husband just got through his employer
so my question is do we just boom just
take these things off today immediately
in full and then we could even maybe
have enough left to go ahead and fund
our full emergency fund or do we just
keep working hold on to that 90,000 and
I'm just wondering I don't really hear a
situation like this to me I like you a
lot you and your husband both and this
is I'm serious because you all have had
the mindset of doing some savings to
begin with and now what I'm about to
tell you
Hilary take a deep breath for me oh all
right good
here's what I'm gonna tell you you're
about to start writing some checks all
right now here's the deal this student
loan you're about to tell forty-three
thousand dollars worth the student loan
by you're getting ready to evict it
you're gonna get it out of your life
you're gonna pay off this car I mean
seriously and you look at that and what
you were paying like how much you all
paying on student loans right now
gosh couple thousand a month so that's
me going in and making it no no I
understand so you got about two thousand
how much you got going out to the car
each month okay so you've got to almost
twenty three hundred dollars leaving you
each month right now correct
okay here's the deal you paid this off
you've got ninety thousand you pay off
the forty three thousand student loan
the seven thousand on the car and then
you take this and you go we were already
sending out twenty three hundred a month
right so you keep that mindset so you've
got that if you do that you've got your
fully funded emergency fund almost as
well along with that money now you guys
are immediately at baby step four where
you're investing fifteen percent of your
income remember we just got back twenty
three hundred dollars a month for you
you were sending that out you're not
sending that out anymore that makes
sense now listen you're gonna have to
your husband you're gonna have to sit
down and show the numbers on this and
you guys are gonna have to breathe
careful because what's gonna happen is
your blood pressure is gonna spike
because I told you to write and checks
out of this money that you all have been
saving up but see nobody counts the debt
will count the savings but we don't look
at the debt like it's a cousin or
something no it's not it's an enemy it's
stealing from you so write the check get
the student loan out of your life get
the car payment out of your life but
you've got your fully funded emergency
fund start investing in your 401 KS
listen to me you guys are well on your
way
Wow see that is a crucial moment because
most people would just want to let that
money sit there and say okay it's my
safety net while the debt continued to
churn and prime and prime and get bigger
and grow so we've got an opportunity
Hilary and I appreciate you calling in
and listen for all of you out there
listening if your own baby step two and
you've got more than a thousand dollars
sitting in your savings account you need
to use that to attack debt get this debt
out of your life because when you get
the debt out of your life you give
yourself a raise
do you ever think about that you can
give yourself a raise without having to
go in and talk to anybody that you work
with you have to beg anybody you get to
make the decision just by getting more
focused and more serious about attacking
debt